meagan Markel and Prince Harry's new
Canadian neighbors have their backs
MAGIX it's pretty amazing a source tells
ET that the community of north Saanich
where the sussex is our temporarily
living has banded together to protect
their privacy it brings me great sadness
that it has come to this the decision
that I have made for my wife and I to
step back is not one I made lightly I
know I haven't always done it right but
as far as this goes there really was no
other option it's been two weeks since
Harry joined his wife and their eight
month old son Archie in the secluded
Vancouver Island community following
their royal exit I hope that helps you
understand what did it come to that I
would step my family back from all I
have ever known
just take is to take a step forward into
what I hope can be a more peaceful life
but the couple's privacy issues seem to
have followed them across the pond
according to a source local businesses
in the Canadian community we're getting
flooded with requests for details about
Meghan and Harry which got in the way of
them doing business we're told many of
the owners are sympathetic to making in
Harry's wishes for privacy and a more
normal life our source says some of the
owners actually posted signs on their
doors that say the press is not welcome
there
last month Meghan and Harry reportedly
threatened legal action over paparazzi
photos of the Duchess carrying Archie
and walking their dogs near their
current home I won't be bullied into
into into playing a game that's they
kill my mother
but if for some reason Canada doesn't
work out this Sussex is will always have
New York I'll let him sublet my
apartment in Central Park West two
bedrooms
best view of Manhattan yes that's
Madonna offering to let Megan and Harry
sublet her apartment in an Instagram
video she posted on Monday run off to
Canada I'm so boring there
[Music]